I think there's some value to equity
like I'm all about equality over Equity
like you ever see that that Meme of the
three people the short guy the medium
size guy and the tall guy trying to look
over a fence and only the tall guy can
see but there's three boxes and each of
them have one box so the tall guy can
see the medium guy and the small guy
can't see so or it's the other two the
medium guy and tall guy can see a small
guy can't see so they say equity and
they give the boxes of the tall guy to
the small guy and now the small guy now
they can all see but so I understand a
little bit of that sometimes maybe man
but not like an entire Society built
around kneecapping the best among us to
propel those that can't I just to your
example what they're saying is the tall
guy should have to uh kneel down and not
look at look not look past the fence at
all he's got to watch this baseball game
for too long he doesn't need it he can
still see without the box so they take
his box away
they're saying that's not enough